ouais donc c'est vraiment au millimètre
près quoi pas au millimètre mais là le
départ oui il faut vraiment que nos
trois plaques soient à angle droit un
simple carton mais beaucoup de précision
ces guuill en courtois ont décidé de se
lancer dans la fabrication de meubles
dans une matière inédite c'est le carton
de récupération c'était le but de notre
démarche c'était de de faire des meubles
à partir de de cartons qu'on trouvait
qu'on récupérait dans les magasin on a
rien acheté mis à part plus tard le
papier pour coller ou ou la peinture
mais pour l'instant on travaille qu'avec
des matériaux de récupération le carton
est un matériau bien plus solide qu'on
ne l'imagine puisqu'il peut supporter
jusqu'à 150 kg résistant et
biodégradable quand on achète des
meubles en kit en fait ils sont tous
encartonnés et le fait de récupérer les
cartons au lieu de les déposer à
deschetteries pour en faire des meuves
je trouve ça génial notre structure est
partie pour un projet à long terme en ce
qui concerne le développement durable au
sens large et l'atelier confection de
meuble en carton que en carton de
récupération est un atelier
qui qui peut sensibiliser les personnes
et en même temps avoir le la
satisfaction de garder un meuble créé
par eux-mêm ces meubles iront décorer
leur habitation un autre atelier devrait
se faire au 3è trimestre cette fois le
gros mobilier sera à l'honneur de quoi
parfaire encore sa
technique